all of these economic catastrophes have
their origins as bad government policy
it's not the free markets are inherently
unstable governments aren't here the
unstable hi I'm Nick Gillespie from
Reason and today we're talking with
Steve Forbes the occasion of his 70th
birthday more or less and also the
hundred year anniversary of Forbes
magazine the magazine which has been in
his life and blood for many many years
Steve Forbes thanks for talking to
reason good to be with you Nick thank
you let's talk about turning 70 how does
that feel and looking back what are the
highlights of your public career well
70 glad to have made it and at this
stage of life it's nice to have an
excuse guilt free excuse for plenty of
cake cookies and ice cream so not going
to complain in terms of your
achievements of over the years
talk about your forays into the
Republican nomination process for the
presidency and your advocacy of the flat
tax do you feel like that accomplished
what you hoped it would accomplish well
I would like to have won it was more fun
to get more votes than the less votes
and but I do think we got some good
ideas out there even though the US has
not made much progress on the tax front
40 countries and jurisdictions around
the world like Hong Kong about the flat
taxes worked fairly well so this is no
longer laboratory stuff this is
real-world stuff and the disappointment
is that in the last 20 years we haven't
had a presidential candidate make that a
forefront issue a couple of them in the
last election had some variations of the
flat tax but they didn't put it out
there so nobody knew it's like the tree
falls in the forest but if you don't
hear it did it really fall so I'm just
waiting for a political entrepreneur to
do it I would have thought in 2016 when
Trump rose up that the other 16
opponents would have said I got to do
something a little differently or I'm
going to get steamrollered instead they
had all the same kinds of consultants
they made all the same calculations and
they all went down for the count
Shakespeare talked about killing all the
lawyers I think they should kill
political consultants but that's another
subject but in terms of the flat tax tax
simplifications out there Republicans at
least have to pay lip service to it
another thing I think we got out there a
medically idea of medical the savings
accounts now they call them health
savings accounts the idea being patient
should be in control not government not
third parties not bureaucrats not big
companies but we the people individually
and as we got that idea out there and I
think too we gave some credence to the
idea of a new social security system for
younger people and I ran in 96 in
Arizona I shocked on my campaign
colleagues and I said we're going to Sun
City and I'm going to talk about social
security oh you can't do that but once
you make it clear you're not going to
take anything away from them is about
their kids and their grandkids they'll
listen explain a little bit of what your
alternative social security plan was
because that's also something that has
not advanced even as the economics or
the finances of both Medicare and Social
Security have just gone even more in the
tech well on social security for younger
people they'll own their own accounts
personal accounts and that way if
anything happens to you you own it and I
think just change the whole mindset
these are that money that goes to your
account you get your first part-time job
you say well Capital what's that all
about you learn because the result of
your labor not a gift from politicians
or employer you created those resources
they belong to you whole different
mindset I think people would learn more
about money at an earlier age since it's
their own property we're talking about
96 when you were running but you know
even over the past 30 or 40 years a
longer period
our people were savvy about investing or
about kind of economic truisms in terms
of you know if you save a little over a
long period of time you're going to do
pretty well you can't wait until the
very end and try and park a lot of money
or even if you have it I mean do you
feel like we're growing as an investor
society there there's been some progress
because of the rise of 401ks suddenly
okay it's not some magic thing that's
going to appear at age 65 there's
something you have to look after
surprise that hasn't been more real
education
and more real reform done on that front
don't put all your money in the company
stock and basic stuff like that so I
think we have to do a lot more but when
people have something they'll learn
about it you don't make them passive and
therefore they become more active in it
and one of the things that I think has
arisen universally in recent years is
the idea of index funds now have
hundreds of billions of dollars you'll
do if you have low fees and just let the
thing work put in your certain amount
each month or quarter or whatever
by golly you'll do better than most
money managers I think that's becoming
more of a conventional wisdom for a
hundred years of Forbes you know it it's
probably harder for a magazine to last
100 years even than a human being do you
think it is still holding true to the
role that it played a hundred years ago
well I was started by my grandfather BC
Forbes it was an immigrant to this
country grade school education one of
ten children he wanted to be a business
writer and then his own boss so he first
grated from Scotland to South Africa was
really there for the founding with paper
one Spain paper called Iran Daily Mail
work for a Wallace who we later became a
novelist he liked drinks of my
grandfather to write Wallace's
editorials from time to time South
Africa to smaller ponds and so he came
to New York and he always had that
entrepreneurial spirit when he landed in
New York he couldn't get a job most
people say oh I can't get a job but he
did something unusual he went to an
editor and says I'll work for you for
free
you could do that in those so he's an
unpaid intern he is an unpaid intern so
to speak but he took the risk he didn't
know what the editor would take his free
labor and then toss him out but he knew
if he did everything the conventional
way he'd go nowhere and so he eventually
got the job then he had so much energy
he used an assumed name got a job at
another publication and probably the
happiest moment in his life was when the
two editors got into an argument as to
who had the best business writer it was
my grandfather in both cases so
eventually decided he became successful
became a syndicated column for Hearst
big newspaper chain at the time and
Hearst by the way was the care
therefore Citizen Kane so you're the one
with the sled problem yes a rosebud okay
spoiler alert yeah but but my
grandfather decided instead of just
writing about these makers and shakers
he would do it himself so he started
Forbes in 1917 and the first issue he
said the purpose of business is to
produce happiness not to pile up
millions Wow and that comes through even
today I mean a lot of publication
there's always the words of wisdom and
isn't one of the catchphrases something
like in all of your getting get wisdom
edge from Proverbs yeah put it in the
first issue of Forbes although with all
thy getting get understanding yeah there
yeah resonates a hundred years later
yeah do you feel like Forbes is you know
what is the essential role that Forbes
magazine plays now and where do you see
it it when there's hundreds well I think
we're unique from other business
publications and I think this is one
reason why around the world
entrepreneurs identify with Forbes so we
don't see business as evil we don't see
them as miscreants having to be a sad
unless they erect the world and kill all
of us with pollution or bad dog food or
whatever kill your pets we we we we see
it as a noble undertaking and yes human
beings what they are some are going to
go off the rails so from the beginning
my grandfather was somebody said like a
drama critic loved it when you got it
right will hit you hard when you got it
wrong but loved what it all represented
and to him entre for what we call
entrepreneurial capitalism today is how
you enable people to do great things be
creative learn from your mistakes and
your doing while you make other people
better are you optimistic for the next
hundred years
yes given what look a hundred years ago
look at the despite two world wars Great
Depression 9/11 all the catastrophes
we've had a great inflation of the 1970s
the disaster of 2008-2009 by the way all
of these economic catastrophes have
their origins of bad government policy
it's not that free markets are
inherently unstable governments aren't
Herot unstable and what they do but when
you look at all
look at how far we've come even though
they try to discredit apples even though
today you're not supposed to use the
word capitalism or well they retook
about late capitalism ill or whatever up
but but the fact the matter is look at
the huge progress that's been made in
the last thirty years people living in
dire poverty down half over a billion
people as the world has become more
integrated coming out of dire poverty
you look at longevity no big deal today
people of 80s or 90s another little
factoid people dying from natural
disasters down 98 percent because of
structures warning from a confirm a
capitalist system so when you look at
all of that progress I we're going to
right under 100th anniversary issue in
2117 despite all that's going to happen
will be infinitely better off then in a
richer world in terms of quality of life
let's talk about Donald Trump you know
he's about six months in no significant
legislation coming out of the Trump
period so far rate him is give him the
way that you would rate restaurants does
to get a green light a yellow light or a
red light well we used to grade mutual
funds a through F for performance and
right now he hasn't completed a year yet
so I'll give him an incomplete but what
he has done in terms of Gorsuch now not
much having the first term no no
surprise but that's a generational thing
that's going to be 25 years hugely
important not just for his decisions but
his ability to articulate why this is
constitutional people read those
decisions they're going to be impressed
by them like they were with Scalia
hugely important deregulation utterly
unglamorous all presents pay lip service
to it they are actually trying to do
where is let's talk about that a bit
because you know at places like the FDA
the FCC and the EPA is definitely
appointed people who are not really
important Scott Gottlieb has worked at
the FDA is written about the problems he
knows where their strengths are where
the weaknesses aren't can make informed
policy decisions instead of having two
nice to have the right ideology but you
have to know what you're doing EPA
pruitt enormous Lee important
sound change his story starting to see
play out in the energy industry and
education hope they back Betsy DeVos
she's been fighting these wars for
twenty years so these are experienced
veterans net so-called net neutrality
where they in Netflix and others want to
the government to subsidize their costs
of doing their programming getting it
out to we the people know they're going
to attack that here's the question for
you
Trump's budget according to economists
and research that the Whedon bomb Center
at Saint at Washington University and
st. Louis
they said if his budget was enacted as
Britain it would reduce the number of
regulators in the government by
something like 1% or something but it
would actually increase spending by
regulatory agencies by three percent is
it is it more complicated in a way to
get rid of regulation in a regulation I
understand as I understand it would be
on the immigration side and I hope in
the next few years as we talk about it
we start with reforming our own
immigration service so if you come and
play by the rules you're not left in
limbo as can happen with people having
higher lawyers and papers get low it's
it's a disaster so don't punish those
who play by the rules would you expand
immigration illegal immigration because
I think people really well so it a
broader sense than Trump you know is you
know where where is he going wrong where
is he falling short about your account
well I think we'll all despite all this
good stuff on regulation getting Gorsuch
through which is enormous ly important
two big things well actually three one
is health care all right you can't undo
Rome or build Rome in a day but there's
some basics they got to get done to
create a more individual patient
oriented system when you do that by
golly a lot of these other problems
start to disappear like this desire to
impose Electronic Arts that happen
naturally when you will have to please
the patient so in the terms of the
legislation that's what I want to see is
it moving the ball forward there because
then we can build on it room that the
other side's been building on this stuff
of so shrooming Italy for decade after
decade we got to do the same
they're in this for the long haul we're
going to run asleep pursue it that's
where the regular story stuff is
important showing our even our own
people this is nitty gritty stuff that
you do day by day by day and don't think
one thing and then you can retire we
have a here on the white horse so health
care what are the other zones oh and
taxes alright they're not going to get
real tax reform Paul Ryan I think the
body snatchers that got to him in
Washington came up with this crazy 20%
border sales tax so delayed health care
because they worshipped the
Congressional Budget Office like ancient
people would worship idols Vestal
Virgins and the like they they delayed
health care so just make
across-the-board rate cuts like Reagan
did and do the serious reform after next
year's election go to something like a
flat tax legacy great legacy they have
but in the meantime you get the rates
down by golly it'll have a ripple effect
positive through the economy and one of
the things I hope they realize is
they're going to be accused of pandering
to the rich get over it the economy
starts to really have real life nobody
cares nobody cares outside of the belt
women and the mainstream media and then
on money sound money stable money we
have 16 ounces in a pound we have 12
inches in a foot 60 minutes in an hour
no one would argue we should change that
to stimulate the economy yet and the
money measure of value makers it makes
it like a claim check worthless in and
of itself but because of trust we use
that to do numerous complicated
transactions each and every day we've
had huge sufferings from unstable money
not to get too much in the weeds but in
180 years where we had the gold standard
most of the time from Alexander Hamilton
George Washington up to the 70s we had
the highest average growth rates in the
history of human beings and despite all
the convulsions and everything that had
happened since then it's fallen by least
a third or 50 percent compounded if we'd
had those growth rates for another forty
years we'd be 50 percent large so that
but we're not going to go to a gold
standard he'll tell us but in the
meantime recognize you don't manipulate
the currency have the Fed don't talk
about
that bloated portfolio have it run down
now get that money back into the system
again no more zero interest rates that's
manipulates price controls
you know these free marketeers Oh price
controls a bit when the Fed does oh oh
no that that's necessary and one things
we got a hammer home hammer home hard
economies are not machines they are
people and the idea that you can guide
the economy like a pedal in a car is
preposterous well we will leave it there
we have been talking with Steve Forbes
on the occasion of Freedom Fest in Las
Vegas his 70th birthday in the hundredth
anniversary of forbes magazine thanks so
much for talking thank you appreciate it
for reason I'm Nikolas
[Music]
I found